hello and welcome to this video
Domenic 88 it's my opponent let's see
what he's going to do against place my
own line against Petrov I know we go to
four nights I can't please Bishop to b5
against that there are a couple of good
options 94 theoretically cannot see most
respected move others are also well
respected but now divorce what most
professional players play with this lot
of theory and often times some you need
to remember
tons of stuff and at the end you don't
even have a great position okay so I
mean you have a good position but it's
just like the amount of things to learn
is tremendous ok this is a bit odd
sorry taking only five is usually a bad
idea the reason is that after now Knight
f3
I have Bishop to g4 and this is an
really awkward pin you know here I've
got b5 right not sure what this was all
about okay so what do I take here the
knight or the or the bishop yeah
probably not so is it the same
but tickets
Knight takes a for he's got two pawns it
probably doesn't hurt to be precise
about that ticket Knight takes my bishop
is a little bit
I can't go to b6 yeah it's tough to same
couldn't really come to a clear
conclusion them I want to go back though
maybe we should be three was his idea
no ok I'm going here trying to break
that pin probably I will take okay well
I see the matching with the Queen I'm
losing a third pawn no don't want to do
that
now he will probably put his try to put
his night into III and then go to f5 but
I'm quick enough and have to control
that over f5 so nothing much happens
rook e8 e 6 g6 that would be nice so
let's go here I could have taken a -
actually yeah ok it's not a big deal I
think getting this rook into the game
and maybe even getting an initiative
there on the G file will be useful
ok I can also just take now and play
like say Queen to f6 or Queen g7
okay um five let's use this pressure
here don't really see anything great for
him maybe ninety four is an idea
[Music]
it's maybe relatively best yeah I'm glad
you fall I cannot stick twice than only
for due to to the night jumps like he
has this in the stadium once the F file
is opened
mmm aah maybe he can play and yeah let's
see what he does
I came so rookie 3 is going to go d6o on
doesn't really feel all that dangerous
no it takes them so I'm two pieces on
I'm a little bit weak on the back rank
so something to keep in mind
okay Queen III now his Crudup the aide
at the end so shouldn't do that
I came
let's push this back I can check on c5
and then play Queen to e3 yet should
more than queen Queen f6 okay okay let's
just cover this thing on h6 it's it's
okay it's two piece of salmon
hmm yeah no nothing nothing fancy huh
nothing fancy just queen III is good
okay this mm anything there on g3 but
that's the only one let's increment yes
but quite sure what okay
okay so um yeah it was a really odd
really odd way of playing after night
deform
um yeah Knight takes e5 it's just not a
good move
why should probably take on d4 or play
maybe Bishop c4 even but after this you
you sometimes have to reckon with moves
like d5 I don't think it works here like
this is probably not enough
I can always play d6 or something like
that
this is just going to be about equal
yeah that's not a good more simply okay
I went c6 I was actually thinking that
maybe that wasn't most precise there
because if I start d6
I should probably start like this here
Knight f4 f3 and Bishop g4 because if he
would have played the normal move Bishop
c4 and then d6 he might have stuff like
Knight f7 yeah even Knight f4 seems to
be a possibility so my move
c6 was probably not the right move order
you know this is probably better I have
to start like that okay I went c6 but he
went to a four now d6 yeah 9 c4 is just
a blunder but the position after Knight
f3 Bishop g4 is also not much fun the
problem is if you look at something like
this B should be 3y to some in trouble
not h5 I guess yeah or b-59 h5 um it's
just very uncomfortable the black king
queen is coming and you sometimes have
ideas to switch play into the dark
squares even d5 Bishop d6 ideas like
here I'm not sure if you want to play B
files of the same
how to say yeah okay here that stats to
this and now an idea can be to play that
d5 takes Bishop d6 and then go on to h2
as you see the engine gives black a
slight advantage yeah it's tough to say
out what a slight advantage and
disposition means but definitely I've
got a couple of and I put a good
initiative going on
yeah after Knight c4 I'm just winning a
piece there should be three seems to you
better it's a piece still whatever I
think and the engine gives a couple of
inaccuracies but I don't think it
matters all that much here d5 was better
here maybe but I'm just a piece up f3
yeah maybe as long as I keep a fairly
clear advantage I'm okay here with my
play yeah he takes d5 that just gives
away a piece I was thinking that GeForce
may be the toughest tribe and that was
considering if h5 is a move because the
only I can take on d5 huh because I was
seeing that this is like it needs no way
and you can do this but I just take it
and it doesn't really get to anything
that Queen takes I can move the rook
various ways probably to g6 I probably
would have played a try I didn't really
take that into account but it's so good
like him probably okay too
it's still a piece it's got two points
but it's a piece um yeah yeah this
really not much going on the engine
gives a couple of question marks but
again black is so completely winning you
can play many things I have to give some
really enough inaccuracies but yeah if
you minus six or minus 5 or minus 4 it
doesn't matter all that much thanks a
lot for watching